frente a la famosa puerta de la India en
el corazón de nuevo adeli una nueva
atracción deleita a los turistas
esta estatua inaugurada por el Primer
Ministro indio representa a chubash
Sandra Bosch un soldado considerado Un
héroe de la independencia se encuentra
en el mismo lugar en el que estuvo la
Estatua de Jorge quinto el abuelo de la
Reina Isabel II hasta finales de los
años 60
Cuando veo Esa estatua Me siento
orgullosa de ser India
los grandes hombres que sacrificaron su
juventud por la nación deberían tener
sus retratos en todos los cruces del
país
por fin el país empieza a reconocer a
estos Mártires olvidados que han
permanecido en la sombra todos estos
años sin embargo chandra Bosch es una
figura controvertida en la historia
contemporánea del país durante la
Segunda Guerra Mundial los militares
rompieron con el movimiento
independentista y pacifista de para
aliarse con los nazis y Los japoneses
contra los ocupantes británicos al
erigir esta estatua narendra modi está
restableciendo la figura de chandra
Bosch pero para este senador miembro del
partido en el poder el Primer Ministro
nacionalista hindú Busca sobre todo
escribir una nueva página en la historia
de la India
antes era un lugar turístico pero ahora
es un lugar de peregrinación
nacionalista los ingleses se han ido
pero su espíritu sigue dominando el país
su Primer Ministro en arenda Moody ha
iniciado un nuevo movimiento por la
independencia y este movimiento pretende
liberarse de la dominación cultural de
la dominación de las ideas europeas es
una descolonización de nuestros sueños
irónicamente la ceremonia de investidura
tuvo lugar a principios de septiembre
justo horas antes de que se anunciara la
muerte de la reina Isabel II el hombre
fuerte del país también aprovechó para
cambiar el nombre de la avenida más
famosa de la India construida durante
del imperio británico
kingsway o rajpad que significa la
avenida de Los Reyes Se llama ahora
cartavia Paz El camino del deber en
hindi crónica
eran símbolos de la esclavitud
eso ya es cosa del pasado
liberar a la India de la mentalidad
colonial 75 años después de su
independencia es el proyecto de
narendramody según varios economistas
indios Inglaterra lanzó su Revolución
Industrial saqueando los recursos del
subcontinente cantidades estimada de
daños 45 billones según un estudio de
2018 pero para este historiador esta
Cruzada contra el pasado colonial
iniciada por el Primer Ministro no es
más que oportunismo político
Nadie puede decir que la colonización
fue beneficiosa para los colonizados
por supuesto su único propósito era la
explotación de nuestros recursos
la colonización británica destruyó
países enteros sus economías y la vida
de los pueblos colonizados pero no creo
en la descolonización de las Mentes para
mí la descolonización ya ha ocurrido
hablar de esto es solo un instrumento
utilizado para controlar la población
Por qué más cambios de nombre una parte
de la opinión pública quiere una
disculpa para intentar curar las heridas
de episodios sangrientos como la masacre
de yalian walabag en am Richard en el
norte del país el 13 de abril de 1919 el
ejército británico abrió fuego contra
una reunión de independentistas el
balance 379 muertos según los archivos
de la época colonial cuatro veces más
según los indios esos bárbaros
dispararon Desde allí y mire esas marcas
en la pared se puede ver la velocidad y
La potencia de las balas entre las
víctimas estaba el abuelo de mahés
cuando la Reina Isabel vino aquí en 1997
celebramos una manifestación para exigir
una disculpa amar es del que habría
aliviado nuestro dolor pero no hizo nada
protestamos con banderas negras y la
policía nos detuvo
fue de la India esperar disculpas o
reparaciones financieras con la llegada
al Trono de Carlos tercero
diputado y miembro del partido del
congreso en duda sin embargo un gesto
simbólico podría ser un primer paso para
saldar parte de la deuda moral de
Inglaterra con la India la de la
devolución del coinor un precioso
diamante regalado a la reina Victoria en
1849 que según algunos indios fue robado
por la corona británica el coinur es un
asunto delicado porque el diamante se
encontró en la corona de la reina madre
y ahora se transmite entre las reinas
consortes y en mayo en la coronación de
Carlos III muchos en la India se
preguntan llevará la reina Camila a esta
Corona adornada con el Coin nur que
recuerda su robo y apropiación imagina
el simbolismo de ver un objeto tan
importante regresar a la India sería una
forma de espiar sus pecados sería una
forma de decir Vale Nos disculpamos por
esa época pasada No deberíamos habérselo
quitado pero no veo cómo podría ocurrir
la Cruzada anticolonial de narendra modi
Aún está apenas empezando de aquí a
finales de año el parlamento pretende
abolir 1500 leyes que se remontan al
imperio británico todas ellas
consideradas por el gobierno como
arcaicas y obsoletas